[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRETT PERLMUTTER: My
name is Brett Perlmutter,
and I'm the head of Google Cuba.
It is my distinct privilege to
welcome today's Talk at Google,
special guest, world-renowned
musician, stellar human being
hailing from the island of
Cuba, Mr. Harold Lopez-Nussa.
Bienvenidos.
Please join me in welcoming him.
[APPLAUSE]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Today's talk is about
music, and it's not
about just enjoying music.
It's about letting music be
the fabric that binds us.
It's about music being a
tool to bridge countries,
to build bilateral relations,
to build multilateral relations,
to bring people together.
Today's talk is also about Cuba.
It's about what's
happening in Cuba.
It's about why Cuba
punches above its weight
artistically and
creatively, and it's
about using the
internet as a platform
to share this content, this
culture, this rich, rich
musical history with
the rest of the world.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: [LAUGHS]
BRETT PERLMUTTER: Everyone
here is really anxious
to hear from you.
We want to hear your music.
We want to hear your stories.
We're going to have a
lot of questions for you,
but I'd be remiss to start
if I didn't tell the audience
a little bit about you.
Harold was born in
Central Havana, Cuba
to a family of
esteemed musicians.
He started playing piano when
he was only eight years old,
and after that he was
a part of many very
famous and prestigious Cuban
musical conservatories.
After graduating from the
Instituto Superior de Artes,
the ISA, he toured with Omara
Portuondo of the Buena Vista
Social Club, and he worked with
the Cuban National Symphony
Orchestra before
releasing his first album,
"Canciones," in 2007.
Now at a mere age
of 35 years old,
jazz pianist Harold Lopez-Nussa
has attained the kind
of international recognition
that most musicians only could
dream of--
first place at the Montreux
Jazz Festival solo piano
competition; a performance
at Paris's legendary Olympia;
yearly North American
and European tours;
and multiple album
releases to his name.
Lopez-Nussa's music reflects
the full range and richness
of the canon of Cuban music
with its distinctive combination
of classical, folkloric,
and popular elements
as well as the embrace of jazz
improvisation and interactions.
Lopez-Nussa chose the
new album's title,
"Un Día Cualquiera," which
means "just another day,"
because, in his words, "the
idea is to put the music
and the trio together in
a studio and just play,
the way we three do
every day, any day,
like a concert in the
living room of your house."
So welcome Harold
to Google's home.
Today, this is your living room.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - HAROLD LOPEZ NUSSA
TRIO, "ELEGUA"]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[INSTRUMENTAL JAZZ]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - HAROLD LOPEZ NUSSA
TRIO]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - HAROLD LOPEZ NUSSA,
"HIALEAH"]
You deserve some
water after that.
Congratulations,
and thank you so
much for sharing that with us.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: [INAUDIBLE]
wonderful Google experience
for us.
So thank you for [INAUDIBLE].
BRETT PERLMUTTER:
Fabulous [INAUDIBLE]..
You always said
[INAUDIBLE] Your last album
before this was "El Viaje."
So [INAUDIBLE]
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
--Cuban government.
That's how allowed to--
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
--Cuban artists.
So that was a way
that I get this chance
to make a deal with
an American label
and have my first American
label album released, which
was "El Viaje," "The Journey."
So I think that that was
incredible for Cuban people
and for Cuban
artists in my case.
Musicians and painters,
writers, everybody,
we get more growth
from American artists.
We get more growth
from American people.
And I think that's what almost
all the people in Cuba want.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: And
what is "El Viaje"--
what's the trip?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Well, the trip
is you can travel
with the music.
You can travel.
That was the idea.
We did this album with a
Senegal bass player and singer
that we met in Paris, and
all this thanks to the music
because music make us travel
physically and spiritually,
of course.
So that was the point
with "El Viaje," so music
from many different places--
from Africa, from Nairobi,
from Cuba, of course,
and of course from
here the jazz.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: It's fabulous.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Thanks.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: So let's
change topics slightly.
Actually I had the
privilege of seeing
you perform most recently in
Washington, DC at the Kennedy
Center for Performing Arts at
the Artes de Cuba Festival.
And you were there with
your brother and your uncle
and your father, if
I'm not mistaken.
So it's a family affair.
What is the role of
family, and how has that
created your musical identity?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Well,
it's really important for me.
Have the chance
to born in Havana.
My mother, she was
a piano teacher.
My father, he played drums.
My uncle, he played piano.
My grandmother, who teach me
a lot of things about music,
she was a piano player--
no professional,
but a great piano player.
The piano that I have in
my house is from her today.
So they teach us--
they loved the
music, and I think
that I learned
from my grandmother
this that I try
to say every time.
Music puts people together.
I went to many
concerts with her,
and I remembered that she
was telling me all the time,
you see all these people here
just listening to the music.
This help the world.
And I am sure music
help the world--
help people be together,
sitting together no matter
your race, no matter your
religion, no matter anything
politic, no matter anything.
Music is the universal language
and can put people together,
and no doubt about that.
And I grew up taking a lot
of advice from my family,
from my father, from my
uncle, from my mother.
And now to be able to play
with my father and my uncle
in the same band,
it's wonderful.
It's something that I want to
do more and more because now I'm
sharing my music with
them, and they've been
playing my own compositions.
For me, it's very special.
I was learning from them.
They are learning
my own compositions.
This is something that
I really appreciated
and that I really loved to do.
BRETT PERLMUTTER:
That's beautiful.
And are your kids
going to be musicians?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
I don't know.
I have two daughters, and
they dance all the day.
So I don't know if they will
be dancing or musicians,
but they love music.
BRETT PERLMUTTER:
Something related to art.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
That's true, yeah.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: That's great.
So the other thing I wanted
to mention about the Kennedy
Center is, at Google we had
the great fortune to be able
to participate by
live-streaming the event--
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Really?
Wow.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: --so people
could see it live on YouTube.
And we actually had a live
stream set up in Havana
so people in Cuba could see the
live stream, which brings me
to this general concept of,
how can the internet help
promote Cuban arts and Cuban
culture and Cuban music?
How can platforms
like Google or YouTube
help share what's so special
about what you're doing?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: It could
be like the most important way
to promote the art, man.
It's the future.
I mean, this is the way
that things happen today.
And in Cuba we're
far away from that
because we don't have
internet connection.
It's very hard to get
internet connection
everywhere and all that.
So I remember that when I was in
Washington and my family was--
I didn't know that
was thanks to Google,
but thank you because my family
watched it, the concert that
happened at Kennedy Center,
in Cuba, and that was great.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: Fabulous.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Fabulous.
This is unique.
And this is the future.
You cannot stop that.
It's wonderful.
The power to have
internet to promote art
is something that we
need to take with us
and do things with this.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: So if Google
could wave its magic wand
and grant all of your internet
wishes, what would they be?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Sorry?
BRETT PERLMUTTER: So
if we had the ability
to do anything in our magic
ball, if we had magic,
and if we could grant your
wish, what would your wish be?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Oh,
put internet in Cuba.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: OK, [SPANISH]
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Por favor.
Please.
BRETT PERLMUTTER:
[SPANISH] OK, cool.
So I want to talk
about the roots
and the tradition of your
music and your compositions.
You come from a very,
very rich musical history
that I don't think
outside of Cuba people
understand the depth of.
And your music even has
traces of Afro-Cuban music.
I think one of your
songs is [SPANISH]..
Could you tell us a little
bit about the antecedents
of your own music?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Well, yeah.
Definitely our music
have a lot of influence,
different influence, and
we have a great tradition
in Cuba about
traditional Cuban music
that we call popular music.
And we have these Afro-Cuban
related to religious,
to African religions
Yoruba, Abakuá.
The first song that we just
played is called "Elegua."
and Elegua is one of the
gods in the Yoruba religion.
When they do a ceremony, they
sing for Elegua and they have
the batá drums playing a rhythm,
and they have people who sing.
And this composition
that we did is--
we took this root
with this [HUMMING]..
The batá drums make
something like [HUMMING]..
And then they sing, [SPANISH].
We put some voice over there.
So we took that from
there, and then we
tried to put in our
way of today until it
gets more contemporary.
That's from there and
then from the sun,
and from the cha-cha-cha,
from the bolero,
from many, many places.
So I think that our music
have a lot from there
and then, of course,
from the jazz
because we are in love with
jazz and we listen a lot.
I listened a lot to jazz
when I was a kid in my home.
And also with classical
great composers
because the three
of us, we studied
in the school classical music.
This is what we're
learning in Cuba.
When you learn music,
it's just about classical.
So the three of
us, we studied all
of the great classical
and European composers.
So I think it's a mix
between all of these,
and more things are
coming every day.
BRETT PERLMUTTER:
That's wonderful.
So who are your
jazz inspirations?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Well, I have many.
I remember more my
father used to listen
a lot of Miles Davis and
[INAUDIBLE] in my house.
This gives me a lot
of inspiration--
Chick Corea, Herbie Hancock.
My uncle introduced me to
the world of [INAUDIBLE]..
He's a huge fan as well as me.
And then a lot of Cuban
musicians I know from Benny
Moré through Juan
Gonzalez, Bebo Valdés,
the father of Chucho Valdés,
two greatest piano player from
Cuba, from many, many musicians
that inspires us a lot.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: So what was it
like to grow up in your house?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Oh, a little crazy.
We was born-- my brother,
he played drums with me.
We was born in a very little
apartment in Central Havana.
So I remember that
we have the dining
room was the piano of my mother,
and then in a kind of mezzanine
the drums of my father on the
bed of my mother and my father.
So yeah, we have all day friends
of my father coming to my house
and play, some student from
mother coming to my house
and take lessons.
So music was like
part of our day.
Like play baseball,
eat, see television,
and listen to music.
It's something-- yeah.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: It's
basically in your blood.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Yeah, definitely.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: So who here
knows the Buena Vista Social
Club?
I think most, almost everyone.
Tell us about your
experience with Omara?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Well,
that was amazing for me.
Omara, she was
famous in the world
thanks to Buena
Vista Social Club,
but she has been
famous in Cuba forever.
So when I was a kid,
she was from forever.
She is like one of the greatest
artists in Cuba from all times.
I was very lucky to be able to
play with her, travel with her.
I was traveling with
her for three years
all around the world.
I was able to record
with her and invite her
to one of my CDs.
And she's a wonderful person.
She is so smart.
She is so cute.
She's so talented.
That was amazing for me, and
I learned a lot of things.
I learned the respect for the
music at that level is like--
I remember sometimes
we're getting back
from three-month tour
to Cuba, and I was just
sitting in my sofa of my living
room and I put the television.
I saw Omara live on the TV.
I was like, wow!
How she can do that?
She's in the music all the time.
So that's help,
and that gives me
a lot more respect for the music
and more love to the music.
Yeah, she showed me that.
BRETT PERLMUTTER:
So that must have
been one of your most formative
experiences, working with her.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Definitely.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: What else was
another formative experience
in your career?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Oh, many things.
For example, right
now have the chance
to be able to play
in the States was
a dream for me for many years.
Took my music to the
American audience,
and now I have been able to
do it thanks to many people
who helped me--
great manager that I have
that is American, great people
who really support us
and help us to be here
tonight and tomorrow in
Iowa and then in Monterey
and then San Francisco.
And this is wonderful.
This is the most
important for me
is take my music to different
audience, see the reaction,
make new friends,
know new people.
That was always my
dream when I was a kid
and is still my dream.
Get more attention in my
music, this is something
that not many musicians can do.
So I'm very proud and I'm very
grateful to be able to do that.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: So what was
your first visit to the United
States?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Well, with
Omara like some years ago,
maybe 10.
But then with my own [INAUDIBLE]
was like six years ago I think.
I made this little
tour, just my brother
and I. We even was not
able to have a bass
player with us because we
was in the very beginning.
So we did some
concert in California
and we played in New
York for one day.
From there until today we
have been coming every year
like two, three, four times.
So I'm very happy to
be able to do that.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: So
it sounds like you've
learned a lot from your
experience in the United
States.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: I'm sorry?
BRETT PERLMUTTER: It
sounds like you've
learned a lot from your
experience in the United
States.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Yeah, I'm learning,
and mostly I'm learning about
people in the United States
who are incredible.
We are so close from the people,
the real people in the United
States.
In Cuba we have a lot
of things in common.
We love the same things.
We love baseball.
Baseball we love in Cuba.
You love baseball here.
So we love music, of course.
We love jazz in Cuba.
You guys, you love Cuban music.
So it's many things in common.
So I'm very happy to
come here more and more.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: And
we're happy to have you.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Thanks.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: So for
people from the United
States and people
watching around the world,
what should we learn from you?
What should we
learn from Cubans?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Well, I don't know,
maybe that we don't care about--
well, we care, but
even when we are not
able to get all
that we need, we are
able to be happy
with what we have.
I'm sorry, I don't know
if I explain myself.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: Perfect.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: But
yeah, I mean, people in Cuba,
they share a lot of things.
That's what I love
the more in Cuba.
They share sugar.
They share salt.
They share chicken.
They share music.
They share life.
Life is very close
from one for another.
I'm very close with all my
neighborhood over there.
Everybody knows me, say
hello to me in the streets.
For me, I have a lot of support.
I feel that I have a lot of
support from people in Cuba.
So this is something different.
The life is quite
different here.
Sometimes it's not that
good because sometimes
your neighborhood,
he put the music loud
at 1:00 AM in the morning.
You can't say anything
because last weekend you
did the same thing.
But well.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: So
you're on this tour.
You're here in Google New York.
You said you're going to
California, to San Francisco,
and going around
the United States.
You've just been in Spain,
in France, in Japan.
You're from Central Havana.
Did you ever think you
would be doing this?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: No, never.
That was always a dream, but no.
That's more than
I was expecting.
So I'm very, very happy,
and I'm trying to do it--
I hope that I keep the
level to keep doing that
and to deserve that.
This is wonderful.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: It's fabulous.
Well, I have one last question.
But before I ask it, I want
to ask folks from the audience
if they have questions
to please stand up,
and you can come up to the mics
and ask anything and everything
that you would like.
Please, if you just
go up to the mic
so your question is recorded.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Cuban.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Oh, wow.
AUDIENCE: I've
been once to Cuba,
but my parents were born there.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Oh, wow.
AUDIENCE: And my
question is, what do you
miss most about Cuba
when you're abroad?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
When I am outside Cuba?
AUDIENCE: When you're traveling.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Oh, my family--
my family and my friends.
I have two little daughters.
I have a wife and I
have a lot of friends.
And yeah, I miss them a lot.
AUDIENCE: And have your
daughters come to the States?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Yeah, the
bigger one, who have only five,
I took her like 20 days
ago with me for a week.
So she was able to get
to New York, Boston.
She was getting crazy
with United States.
She was telling all
their friends over there,
oh, I was there.
AUDIENCE: Well, your
performance was incredible.
Thank you.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Oh, thanks.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: Thank you.
Please?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
coming and giving us
such a great performance.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: My pleasure.
AUDIENCE: When I was
watching you play like this,
it was totally crazy.
And I'm curious, how much is
improv versus you're going
to play exactly that stuff?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Oh,
there's a lot of improv, yeah.
We have a song that
we do, just the song,
and then it's just
improvisation.
So we took from there and
we tried to create things.
And of course when you do
this every day, sometimes
you do same thing, that same
phrase that you did yesterday.
But we are always trying to
don't do the same things.
So this is the
complicated part, to be
able to create every
day a different phrase,
a different freedom
in the improvisation.
But there is a lot, definitely.
And with those guys who
knows me that well, for me
it's very easy.
They always give me
something to create.
So yeah, we listen to each
other a lot, and from there
we try to create and create.
AUDIENCE: Was it hard to
learn music from your parents?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: No,
they helped me a lot.
They helped me a lot.
My mother, she was
sitting with me
in the piano when I was a kid
trying to study and practice
with me a lot.
I was like, argh, I don't want.
I want to play baseball.
And she goes, no, you need
to do it one more time.
But thanks to that I am
able today to play piano.
But they support me a lot, not
just when I was a little kid.
Then when I was trying to
change from classical music
to play something else
like jazz or Cuban music,
they support me a lot.
I didn't have the
support from my teachers,
but I do have from my family.
So I'm very grateful
for all the support
that they give me until today.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: Thank you.
I think we have another
question over here.
AUDIENCE: Are you playing
any shows in New York
while you're here?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: No, not now.
We was playing at the
Jazz Standard tonight
and at the end of July.
AUDIENCE: And my second is, I
was wondering if you could just
talk about the future of jazz
music and what you think,
like where it's going?
Because I feel like it's been
a medium that's kind of stayed
standing still for a long time,
and I'm wondering where do you
see it going in the future?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Jazz in general?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Well, I think
that there's a lot of young
musicians trying things.
It's sometimes hard
because jazz is not
getting that big attention
in the world, unfortunately.
But there's still
great festivals
all around the world in Europe,
in Asia, here in the States.
And there is a lot of young
people trying to do things.
That's where we
are trying to take
from what we know
from our [INAUDIBLE]
and put new things into that.
So there is people doing
it here in the States.
New York is, of course,
it's the top of the top.
Here there is so
many jazz artists
from all around the world.
But there is people in Europe.
There's people in Cuba.
There's a lot of young people
doing things, incredible.
Unfortunately not everyone is
able to take his art to here.
But I think that I don't know.
I don't know for
sure, but we will try.
We will try to get
the jazz active,
of course, and get attention
from more people, yeah.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: I have
one last question for you,
and it's about the
last song that you're
going to play for us, which I
believe is called "Hialeah."
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Oh, we just played.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: Oh,
you already played it?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Sorry,
I always change the--
BRETT PERLMUTTER: The order.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
--the schedule.
Sorry.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: OK.
So--
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
But yeah, "Hialeah."
"Hialeah" is a neighborhood
in Miami where a lot of Cubans
live there.
It's like a little Cuba.
You go there and there's people
playing dominoes on the street.
Music is loud.
They share sugar and
chicken also over there,
so it's almost like Cuba.
When I was there my first
time, they blew my mind,
so I wrote this little
piece for Hialeah.
And I call it like that.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: And
what does it mean to you?
What is Hialeah and,
more broadly, Miami?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
Oh, you know in Cuba we
listen a lot of bad
sins about Miami people.
They are the gang in Cuba.
Then again are
political over there.
And when I first visited
Miami I was like at home,
and I have so many
friends over there.
I have family, friends.
It's almost Cuba.
When I get off from the
plane, they speak Spanish.
They are close to United States,
but they are almost Cuba.
So I feel so well over there.
And all the times that I get
there, I have a great time.
So I love Miami.
BRETT PERLMUTTER:
Well, I actually
think that kind of brings
us full circle to where
we started, that your
life's experience,
your music is really
testament to the fact
that we have so much in common--
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Definitely.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: --so much
to learn from each other,
and so much to
share back and forth
and with the rest of the world.
So thank you for doing that
here with us at Google New York.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: My pleasure.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: And you
have one more song for us.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: Oh, yeah.
So as I changed--
let me see.
I think that we're going to
play a song by my brother.
The name is "Guajira."
And guajira is a kind of
music from the country--
the countryside--
BRETT PERLMUTTER: Of Cuba?
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: --so
the countryside of Cuba,
so like country music
from Cuba, I don't know,
something like that.
So "Guajira," we're
going to play for you.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: All right,
well thank you so much.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA:
No, thank you.
Thanks so much.
It's a pleasure.
Thank you.
BRETT PERLMUTTER: Gracias.
[APPLAUSE]
I'll take this from you.
Thank you.
HAROLD LOPEZ-NUSSA: By the
way, Gastón Joya on bass.
[APPLAUSE]
And Ruy Adrian
Lopez-Nussa on drums.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC, HAROLD LOPEZ NUSSA TRIO,
"GUAJIRA"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.